selber zeit mit meinen kindern
verbringen das war der ansatzpunkt dafür
zwar im normalen alltag nicht irgendwann
freitagabend ankommen und sonntagmittag
wieder los sondern ganz normal wenn die
morgens in die kita gehen oder heute in
die schule gehen dass man im alltag
einfach teil hat ich hätte gerne auch
ein jahr elternzeit gemacht also die
mutter ein jahr ich ein jahr vielleicht
noch bis meine tochter in die schule
kommt dann durchaus dem teilzeit
doch sein chef war der gegen kiel
fürchtet er immer noch deshalb möchte er
nicht erkannt werden
zwei väter in deutschland und ihre
erfahrungen mit kind und karriere
jörg asmussen ist deutschlandweit
bekannt ein spitzenökonom politisch
vernetzt
der sozialdemokrat war staatssekretär
und galt als einer der wichtigsten
beamten in der finanzkrise
anschließend stieg auf ins direktorium
der europäischen zentralbank
und dann wäre gerne bei der ezb
geblieben es war einfach eine tolle
aufgabe geld für die sich für ganz
europa zu machen es hat bei der ezb auch
sehr viel verständnis und hilfe gegeben
das war nun mit dem einen hauptquartier
frankfurt für die euro zone und dem
damit verbundenen faktischen pendeln war
das nicht so wollen mit dem damals noch
sehr kleinen kindern sein abgang eine
entscheidung die für aufsehen sorgte
ich war überrascht was für die welle von
mails und post ist gab und es war ein
ganz breites spektrum jahr zwischen du
bist vorbild und du bist vollidioten
kleinkinder betreut von ihren vätern
aktive vaterschaft das wünschen sich in
deutschland immer mehr männer
doch nicht selten stoßen sie auf
vorurteile und widerstand beim
arbeitgeber er zum beispiel wollte sich
um seine tochter kümmern als sie klein
war
doch der versicherungsvertreter hatte
pech den falschen chef für solche ideen
unser chef hat es abgelehnt und da auch
ziemlich übel drüber hergezogen keine
richtigen männer und kinder kümmern sich
auf frauen da können sie auch
strumpfhosen hinziehen alles so was also
richtig abwertend nach dem motto der
mann ist dann ein weichei wenn er sich
ums kind kümmert das waren so wirklich
gusseiserne vorstellungen die irgendwo
noch aus dem letzten jahrtausend stamm
die ein gebiet mehr in die heutige zeit
passen hat mir aber trotzdem nichts
geholfen
am ende zählt das sichere einkommen für
die familie den job wechseln
die möglichkeit hat nicht jeder auch bei
mir war es in dem fall nicht möglich
in der abteilung wechseln auch schwierig
es ist einem nichts damit gedient wenn
man seine elternzeit nimmt aber damit
dann in zukünftigen jahren repressalien
hat und die karriere des spitzen ökonoms
von der ezb wechselte er nach berlin ins
bundesarbeitsministerium
doch der nächste karriereschritt bislang
zu einer der führenden förderbanken
weltweit der kfw streitpunkt
vereinbarkeit mit der familie dass das
café gegen nicht geklappt hat das gönnt
sich den karriereknick danach musste mal
neu anfangen
ich persönlich war frustriert ja aber da
muss man auch darüber hinweg gucken und
neue dinge machen gibt einen neuen guten
job gefunden wir gute arbeitgeber von
vornherein wusste okay der meint das
wirklich ernst ja sagen würde als ich
dann sagte pass auf berlin ist wichtig
finde ich wie in der kinder sagt mir
gleich das haben wir bei ihnen schon
verstanden ja ich glaube dass es
leichter ist nochmal seine
kinderbetreuungs aufgabe auch wahnsinn
wenn man in der hierarchie schon relativ
weit oben ist dann gilt das inzwischen
bisschen als chic aber das ist eben
nicht flächendeckend ja die frage ist
kriegen wir das für alle vernünftig so
hin
er war nicht oben in der hierarchie kam
im entscheidenden moment nicht an seinem
chef vorbei also ich bedauere es für
mich auf jeden fall das ist eine zeit
die nicht zurück zu bringen ist ich kann
es auch nicht mehr nachholen es fehlt
einfach ein stück was im leben und ich
könnte es wirklich jedem vater heute der
das erleben kann und die zeit aufwendet
sich für seine kinder zu engagieren
er war wie die meisten väter nur am
wochenende präsent viele junge väter
heute aber nehmen sich die zeit am
ehesten die die sich das beruflich
erlauben können die diese ärzte
wissenschaftler und experten bei
gefragten berufen gelingt nach der
erziehungspause der wiedereinstieg
besser ich wünsche mir dass das normal
wird das gilt für männer wie für frauen
das ist nichts besonderes angesehen und
nur das will so das ist teil des wie wir
leben wie wir arbeiten und dass das wenn
meine töchter groß sind dass das völlig
normal ist dass man eben arbeitet und
seine kinder genauso auch großziehen in
deutschland nehmen sich väter derzeit im
durchschnitt drei monate elternzeit
mütter 13 monate